bonsoir et bienvenue à vous regarder en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
vous Gérald Brunner bonsoir vous êtes
sociologue grand spécialiste des
croyances collectives et dans votre
dernier livre vous mélangez parcours
personnel et réflexions théorique autour
du grandes questions c'est moi que l'on
puisse dire pourquoi devient-on qui l'on
est va se programme c'est un plaidoyer
pour la complexité des origines qui
interroge à la fois les déterminismes
l'héritage familial mais aussi le mérite
et les mythes personnels c'est
passionnant ça fait écho au débat sur le
travail et sur les retraites on en parle
tout à l'heure mais on va commencer avec
la séquence qui s'ouvre justement sur la
réforme des retraites d'un côté le
mouvement social se durcit de l'autre le
Sénat adopte la mesure phare le recul de
l'âge à 64 ans la course contre la
montre et donc lancer les députés
pourraient même voter jeudi prochain à
condition d'avoir une majorité retraite
comment ça va se terminer grande
décryptage dans un instant avec nos
invités avant de retrouver bien sûr aux
alentours de 20h20 nos affranchis pour
leur parti pris ils vont vous
interpeller Gérald Bronner vous me
suivez savoir garde c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est donc la semaine de tous les
dangers sur la réforme des retraites le
vote solennelle sur le texte pourrait
même intervenir jeudi au Parlement mais
d'ici là vous le savez il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses à la fois dans la rue
et à l'Assemblée alors on va faire le
point sur les scénaris possibles et tout
vous expliquer des rapports de force au
Palais Bourbon avec deux journalistes
d'abord elles avaient bonsoir évidemment
de près pour LCP cette réforme
jean-rébie baudotoir de France Info le
brief politique tous les matins 7h24 et
puis avec un constitutionnaliste bonsoir
Dominique sagnolo bienvenue président du
Cercle des constitutions analystes et un
syndicalistes dans l'âme bien sûr
Jean-Claude Mailly ancien secrétaire
général de Force Ouvrière alors qui de
la rue ou du Parlement oral dernier mot
votre regard de sociologue nous
intéresse forcément Gérald Bronner sur
la question mais d'abord on va parler du
calendrier le calendrier social et
politique s'aligne dans cette dernière
ligne droite comme nous l'explique
Stéphane Stéphane blackovski le chrono
de black o c'est parti
et je me retourne pour vous accueillir
comme chaque soir ces femmes bienvenue
bonsoir Myriam salut Elsa bonsoir
messieurs alors que va-t-il se passer
dans cette dernière ligne droite
jeudi prochain dans huit jours la
réforme des retraites pourrait être voté
le matin au Sénat voter l'après-midi à
l'Assemblée ce qui fait qu'à la fin de
la journée et ben voilà le texte serait
adopté donc 8 jours décisifs ou inter
syndical et gouvernement ont chacun
sortit leur agenda pour cocher l'État
les cages décisives donc on va commencer
par l'agenda de l'Inter syndicale
première date cocher par l'intersyndical
dans deux jours samedi grosse manif
prévue les gens travaillent pas il y
aura peut-être encore plus de monde
alors quel sera le chiffre je ne sais
pas je vous rappelle simplement que
quand le ministère de l'Intérieur dit
qu'il y a eu un million 272 000
manifestants les syndicats disent que
c'était beaucoup plus peut-être ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce chiffre il n'a
jamais été atteint c'est le record
absolu au niveau du ministère pour une
manifestation de syndicats protestants
contre une réforme
comme quoi il y a vraiment une vraie
mobilisation mais côté gouvernement si
on change d'agenda ce n'est pas la date
du 11 qui a été coché en premier en
revanche c'est celle du 12 le lendemain
on voit qu'il y a marqué adopte sur du
texte Sénat ça c'est ce qu'espère le
gouvernement évidemment ça veut dire que
les sénateurs ont jusqu'à dimanche 12
min pour examiner cet article vous savez
qu'ils ont déjà voté cette nuit
l'article 7 sur la prolongation
progressive jusqu'à 74 ans il y a quand
même 20 articles total à examiner est-ce
qu'ils auront le temps de le faire à
l'Assemblée on n'a pas été plus loin que
trois articles donc Olivier du stop lui
croise les droits l'Assemblée nationale
seul les deux premiers articles ont été
examinés ils n'ont pas aller jusqu'à
Arthur là nous en sommes à l'article 7
et nous allons continuer à débattre avec
l'espoir pour le gouvernement que nous
puissions débattre de tous les articles
du texte d'ici à dimanche soir
l'espoir du gouvernement donc on dit si
le texte est adopté mais c'est probable
donc ensuite il y a une date qui a été
cochée vous voyez que c'est la même
chose de part et d'autre le mercredi 15
donc manif TTG ça veut dire manif très
très grosses ça c'est ce qu'elle se perd
l'Inter syndical côté gouvernement un
autre code CMP CMP ça veut dire
commission mixte paritaire c'est une
commission qui réunit cette députés
cette sénateurs et qu'on réunit quand le
Sénat et l'Assemblée n'ont pas réussi à
se mettre d'accord sur un texte
généralement il trouve assez facilement
un compromis là c'est un peu particulier
parce que en fait il n'y aura pas de
texte proposé par l'Assemblée puisque
ils n'ont pas été au bout de l'examen
donc la Commission va simplement
examiner la version du Sénat en espérant
ben pour le gouvernement bien sûr
l'affaire adopter donc est-ce que ça
sera adopté on peut regarder et on ne
sait pas encore la composition ce qu'on
est président du Sénat et de l'assemblée
qui vont désigner les gens mais la
dernière fois qu'on a réuni une
commission mixparitaire il y avait
quatre renaissances quatre républicains
bah ça y est on est déjà 8 pas majorité
à 7 donc voilà c'est l'espoir du
gouvernement de pouvoir faire
accepter cette réforme alors bien sûr on
revient à notre agenda et voyez que le
gouvernement là espère évidemment le 16
le jour du vote une adoption mais ça va
être un peu bizarre quand même parce que
la veille il y aurait eu combien un
million un million et demi s'il y a 2
millions on dira plusieur million de
Français dans la rue et finalement la
réforme et leur a été décidée par 14
personnes en fermant huis clos dans
l'assemblée est-ce que les syndicats
vont accepter ça on a demandé à Philippe
Martinez deviner ce qu'il a répondu
adopter une telle réforme qui touche au
quotidien des citoyens de cette façon là
je pense que c'est déjà assez compliqué
mais ça peut mettre le faux poudre ah le
feu aux poudres on sait ce que ça fait
ça fait boom l'explosion sociale que
pronostic éventuellement Philippe
Martinez on regardera dans l'agenda où
il y a encore pas mal de cases de livres
donc ce qui est possible c'est comme les
syndicats demandent un rendez-vous
Emmanuel Macron s'il pouvait caser
peut-être un rendez-vous dans l'agenda
ça ferait baisser l'attention je sais
pas en tout cas l'appel est lancé on va
y revenir Jean-Claude Mahy déjà sur le
moment
social qu'on traverse après un succès un
nouveau succès de la de la sixième
journée d'action est-ce qu'on rentre
dans une un début de radicalisation
selon vous il y a eu des débordements
enfin des coupures dans village de
courant au village olympique autour du
stade de France c'était la CGT il y a
des blocages dans les raffineries même
s'il y a pas de pénurie d'essence pour
le moment il y a des perturbations dans
les transports est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que l'Inter syndicale est
dépassée par sa base ou pas non je pense
pas qu'elle soit dépassée là il peut y
avoir ici ou là quelques actions qui ne
correspondent pas obligatoirement à ce
que souhaite les confédérations et vous
savez ça a toujours été comme ça dans
les mouvements dans les mouvements
sociaux non mais on rentre dans une
période de compliquée parce que si on
suit le réseau imaginons que le texte
soit voté ou parce qu'ils ont une
majorité ou 49-3 c'est pas fini pour
autant au moins pour pour deux raisons à
la fois d'une certaine manière considère
que président a publié lui-même piéger
dans son système en ce sens c'est lui
qui annonce la réforme au départ 65 et
après 64 donc il est porteur de la
réforme et après il est en recul depuis
le début ensuite vous pensez que les
Français ne passeront pas autre chose il
y aura toujours des mouvements je sais
pas c'est un mais ce n'est pas exclu
voilà ce que je peux dire j'enseigne
c'est pas moi je suis pas en situation
de décider mais
ce qui fait regarder dans les
manifestations les gens ne disent rien
sur la première ministre ils ne disent
pas sur le ministre du travail y compris
quand il dit des bêtises par contre
c'est le président de la République qui
est visé parce que c'est lui qui annoncé
ça à un moment donné et là il veut pas
recevoir donc il est un peu piégé et
Laurent Berger qui demande à être reçu
qu'ils ont même écrit au Président de la
République il y a cette phrase dans la
lettre au président pour nos
organisations cette absence de réponse
pour l'heure constitue une grappe un
grave problème démocratique il conduit
un manquablement à une situation qui
pourrait devenir explosive oui d'accord
avec ça
mais ça peut vouloir dire si vous voulez
un moment donné quand vous faites des ce
qu'ils ont fait depuis le début les
syndicats ensemble tous unis des
manifestations sans gros problèmes il y
a des petits incidents mais sans
problème toute une série de
manifestations que ils ont un mur en
face de un moment donné vous pouvez pas
vous arrêter comme ça c'est pas possible
et même s'il s'arrêtait comme ça moi je
vous garantis que dans la foulée je sais
pas mais il y aura un effet boomerang
encore parlé quelle nature l'effet
boomerang c'est important
vous qui suivez l'Élysée notamment
qu'est-ce qu'on dit à l'Élysée est-ce
que ils vont être reçus finalement ou
pas Laurent Berger et Martinez pour
l'instant vous avez noté la phrase de
l'Élysée la réponse au soir de la
manifestation de mercredi de mardi
c'était la porte de l'exécutif est
toujours restée ouverte c'est pas la
porte de l'Elysée et donc manifestement
pour l'instant le président de la
République n'a pas prévu de se mettre en
scène avec les syndicats ce qui est
quand même incroyable effectivement
comme le dit Jean-Claude à l'instant
c'est que dans la plupart des conflits
sociaux des 10 20 des dernières années à
chaque fois le contact est resté en 2019
les syndicats étaient toujours
reçus par Édouard Philippe parfois ça
durait 10 minutes avec avec Philippe
Martinez mais il était reçu la loi el
khomri pareil même à l'époque de Nicolas
Sarkozy
soubis discuter avec les syndicats là on
est vraiment dans une situation très
particulière où le gouvernement discute
avec la droite exclusivement avec la
droite et en réalité la droite
sénatoriale principalement et ne discute
pas avec les corps intermédiaires en
réalité c'est tout à fait à l'image du
macronisme tel qu'on le connaît depuis
le début à savoir se passer des corps
intermédiaires le problème c'est quelle
conséquence sociale c'est la satrice
rossignol qui posait la question cette
semaine au ministre de du travail qui
disent dans quel état est-ce que vous
allez laisser le pays et cette question
malgré tout se pose puisque s'il n'y a
pas de discussion quand il y a pas de
discussion un moment ou un autre et ben
il se passe quand même quelque chose
soutient majoritairement le mouvement
même s'il y a un peu de résignation
parce que les Français pensent que une
finelle sera adopté cette réforme si le
pays commence à connaître des blocages
elle peut se retourner c'est c'est le
pari de l'exécutif alors justement c'est
vraiment sur ces chiffres que ça puis la
majorité la réforme elle est impopulaire
on le sait mais il y a une résignation
il y a deux tiers des Français qui
pensent qu'elle sera adoptée donc ce qui
fait penser à la
[Musique]
je crois purement de nature politique ce
qui frappe d'abord si vous voulez sur
l'horloge revient au droit un peu c'est
la procédure parce que à ce rythme là
dans les étudiants commencent à
connaître aussi bien l'article 49-3 que
l'article 47 ans c'est bon ou mauvais
signe dans ma génération c'était
l'article 16 vous voyez enfin on
apprenait alors là 47 ans pour
l'avantage le premier c'est que d'abord
il y a pas d'évaluation réelle
officielle c'est pas la réforme Balladur
il y a pas d'avis du Conseil d'État
complet il est secret d'ailleurs encore
enfin il est toujours à moitié secret
maintenant il est fuite partout il y a
un débat qui est contraint donc c'est
quand même très rare même s'il peut y
avoir un tour législatif programmé à
l'Assemblée nationale ici et puis et
puis enfin on peut utiliser l'article en
phosphore répétition dans les projets de
finance et puis on peut enfin on peut
même si ça va pas utiliser utiliser des
ordonnances on va y venir dans le détail
Gérald Bruner le regard du sociologue
m'intéresse parce qu'on a l'impression
que voilà il un débouché
quel que soit l'issue c'est-à-dire une
issue favorable forcément les syndicats
seraient contents mais si le texte est
voté cette colère peut se transformer
elle va elle va elle va forcément
déboucher sur quelque chose mais on ne
sait pas quoi alors en tant que
sociologue je me garde bien de faire des
prévisions de ce genre je me méfie aussi
un peu de des approches du monde social
en termes de métaphore c'est la
cocotte-minute etc on a tous ce
sentiment là mais ça veut pas dire grand
chose en réalité je crois quand même que
dans la dans la séquence qu'on vient de
de vivre et qu'on n'a pas encore fini de
vivre d'ailleurs les syndicats en
ressortent assez renforcé c'est un des
enjeux qu'on qu'on pouvait interroger au
départ qui allait gagner qui allait
perdre beaucoup jouer beaucoup dans
cette affaire que ça soit le
gouvernement l'opposition qui elle a
incarnée l'opposition politique et les
syndicats qui avaient été débordés à
plusieurs reprises par des mouvements
n'ont pas spontané mais en tout cas qui
trouvaient leur niche dans les réseaux
sociaux et qui ne voyaient pas
apparaître comme par exemple la le
mouvement sociaux des contrôleurs
aériens si je si je me rappelle bien et
et ensuite les syndicats ont beaucoup de
mal à contrôler ça le syndicat de
catalyse voilà massif et de façon unique
et avec un front avec un front syndical
il est pas certain qu'il puisse mais le
contraire n'est pas certain non plus
qu'il puisse bénéficier d'un du
sentiment de dégoût que va peut-être
qu'il va peut-être naître suite à
l'adoption de ce de ce texte de cette
réforme ce qui est très intéressant
aussi c'est que on s'est inquiété de
savoir si Macron Emmanuel Macron allait
recevoir les syndicats et ce qui a pas
été le cas de précédent le président de
la République donc on voit bien que
c'est lui qui incarne individuellement
c'est ça qui est intéressant aussi en
termes de narration parce que par la loi
el khomri c'était la la loi el khomri et
puis on a beaucoup d'autres exemples de
cette nature donc on voit qu'il y a un
clivage ensuite en effet comment va
s'incarner se ressentiment mais en fait
ça dépend des narrations qui vont être
proposées débouchés politiques débouchés
violents pas forcément débouché enfin
politique dans le sens large du terme
mais pas forcément débouchés politiques
dans le sens répartition du de pouvoir
parler parti ou par les incarnations
c'est à dire qu'on vit quand même une
désintermédiation dont les réseaux
sociaux sont une incarnation mais il y a
aujourd'hui des offres politiques qui
sont souvent caractérisées par le
populisme qui précisément joue sur cette
désintermédiation par exemple on se
passe des journalistes on communique
directement par Twitter pour parler de
certains leaders États-Unis qu'on a
qu'on a encore en mémoire et c'est
désintermédiation elle fait des offres
narratives qui vont dans le sens des
attentes je dirais intuitives de ce que
nous sommes moi y compris en tant
qu'individu et en tant que électeur et
ces formes intuitives elles prennent des
formes politiques qui s'incarnent pas
forcément dans les urnes on l'a vu un
des plus manifeste exemple c'est le
mouvement des gilets jaunes que personne
n'avait vu venir qui est né sur par des
groupes facebook privés colères
départemental etc et qui tout à coup est
devenu un peu incontrôlable parce que il
ne pouvait pas désigner de leaders
les gilets jaunes ont obtenu ce qu'il
voulait sur la taxe carbone par quand
même de la radicalité de la violence
parce que je sais pas si le chiffre est
exact mais j'ai en tête le plus gros
journée de mobilisation c'est 200 ou 250
manifestants et ils ont obtenu presque
20 milliards donc le ratio est quand
même assez assez important alors que là
on voit 1,2 millions dans la rue certes
le pays n'était pas bloqué et là encore
le narratif syndical et un peu tombé à
plat parce qu'ils avaient dit ce sera
une journée où le pays va être à la
règle etc bah non les dans les dans les
rues les tous les ça n'était pas la
grève générale en tout cas ce qui veut
pas dire que c'était pas un mouvement
important et massif mais ça n'était pas
la grève générale donc d'une certaine
manière la tue le gouvernement à l'issue
de cette de cette soirée là moi j'ai eu
plusieurs ministres au téléphone ils me
disent c'était pas le grand soir et donc
eux ils sont un peu rester là-dessus en
disant bon ben voilà la France se
mobilise mais on continue ça peut donner
voilà des des crédits à l'action plus
violents
quand vous avez des mouvements sociaux
pensent souvenez-vous les portiques de
Madame Ségolène Royal bon au bout d'un
certain moment elle a réussi à la finit
par les bon ce que je veux dire c'est
quand c'est un mouvement social Kelly un
projet de loi il est assez rare qu'un
gouvernement recule c'est arrivé une
fois en 95 mais quand oui il y a 86 et
quand c'est délié enfin si je puis dire
ou une mesure ou un décret et quand
c'est lié à une mesure gouvernementale
simple j'allais dire c'est plus facile
de faire un problème de domaine
sectoriel vous voyez par exemple il y a
un problème de majorité on en parlera
certainement mais la question est-ce que
à la fin infini le gouvernement à la
légitime côté Parlement comment le
gouvernement va chercher les voies à
droite et bien c'est simple une à une
confiance ou inquiétude quelle est
l'état d'esprit en coulisse dans la
majorité Thibault note a mené l'enquête
à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est une histoire de calcul avec une
majorité absolue actuellement fixée à
287 voix à l'assemblée et des troupes
macronistes au nombre de 250 il faut en
théorie 37 voix venues d'autres groupes
pour être certain d'adopter la réforme
des retraites jeudi prochain dans
l'émission une équation simple sur le
papier mais très mouvante dans la
réalité et à laquelle s'appellent les
négociateurs du gouvernement et de la
majorité la première ministre Elisabeth
borne le ministre du Travail Olivier du
soft celui des relations avec le
Parlement Franck Riester et la
présidente du groupe Renaissance Aurore
berger sont à la manœuvre message coup
de fil comptage quotidien ils savent que
chaque suffrage pourrait être décisif il
faut s'en assurer un à un
premier enjeu les 250 voix de la
majorité seront elles bien 250 depuis le
début des débats une poignée de députés
macronistes menace de faire défaut il
faut donc déjà resserrer les rangs le
groupe Renaissance pourrait-il exclure
les députés qui ne voteraient pas en
faveur de la réforme la question fait
débat au sein de ses rangs deuxième
enjeu le vote des oppositions tous les
groupes sauf les républicains sont
opposés à la réforme au maximum cela
pourrait se traduire par 270 à 280 voix
contre la loi jeudi prochain reste les
députés les républicains ils sont 61
c'est eux qui pourraient faire pencher
la balance
l'exécutif a fait beaucoup ces dernières
semaines pour s'attirer leur faveur
donnant le feu vert à plusieurs de leurs
demandes mais rien n'est acquis d'après
les derniers comptages 30 à 40 députés
LR devrait voter pour la réforme une
dizaine pencherait pour l'abstention et
une quinzaine envisagerait de voter
contre des voies que la majorité espère
encore pouvoir aller chercher mais qui
resterait
réputé Aurélien Pradier a rencontré le
patron de la CFDT Laurent Berger en
compagnie d'une quinzaine de ses
collègues et fait passer un message au
gouvernement nous sommes favorables à
une réforme mais pas n'importe quelle
réforme on n'est pas dans une caserne on
n'est pas des députés dociles et soumis
aux ordres des uns et des autres on est
députés qui assument nos missions en
réfléchissant et en pensant chacun
librement l'enjeu pour le gouvernement
pourrait être d'obtenir au moins une
abstention de la part de ces
récalcitrants une abstention qui
permettrait de faire baisser le seuil de
la majorité et donc le nombre de voix
pour nécessaire à l'adoption de la loi
autant d'équations déterminante car
elles vont influer sur le choix de
l'exécutif s'il n'est pas certain
d'avoir une majorité c'est un autre
chiffre qui pourrait sortir de sa
calculette le 49-3
tout cela de près et en coulisses l'état
d'esprit de la majorité à huit jours là
dans votre possible c'est quoi confiance
fébrile alors un peu confiant quand on
leur pose la question certains nous
disent on fait des tableaux on calcule
et pour nous ça passe mais tout de suite
après il s'inquiète pourquoi parce que
vous vous pensez que ça passera pas
qu'est-ce qu'on vous raconte etc donc on
voit que ça dénote une certaine
fébrilité moi je pense que c'est très
compliqué j'ai eu des députés les
républicains au téléphone tout à l'heure
et ils me disent qu'ils ne savent pas ce
qu'ils vont faire donc je vois pas
comment la majorité aurait pu les
classer dans une case pour contre ou
abstention et ça je sais qu'il y en a
plusieurs donc je pense qu'il va y avoir
des calculs qui vont être faits on se
souvient pendant la loi travail
d'Emmanuel Macron c'était une heure
avant une demi-heure avant on était en
train de calculer si ça passait ou pas
Emmanuel Macron connaît le 49-3 il a
subi sur un texte
c'est de savoir à partir de quelle marge
de manœuvre on peut considérer qu'on
peut aller au vote parce que si c'est à
une voix près deux voix près est-ce
qu'on peut prendre le risque d'y aller
et ça risque de se jouer on l'a vu sur
les différents calculs à vraiment très
très peu de voix d'ailleurs on a parlé
d'une éventuelle exclusion des députés
de la majorité qui ne voteraient pas bon
finalement cette information a été
corrigée manifestement mais ça en dit
long sur la fébrilité au sein des
troupes Renaissance j'aurais aimé c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que c'est aussi
perçu à droite c'est intéressant j'ai
discuté avec un baron de la droite comme
on dit un des cadres de SLR qui disait
en gros ils nous mettent la pression
mais ce serait bien aussi que chez eux
en fait il fasse aussi le ménage parce
que s'il manque des voix s'il manquera
peut-être des voix chez eux donc ça
c'est quand même un point après c'est
quand même somme toute assez classique
dans n'importe quel n'importe quel
moment quand il y a un texte financier
en général si on ne vote pas un texte
financier c'est qu'on se place deux
facto dans l'opposition cette réforme
passant par un texte financier d'un
point de vue très classique sont
négocies avec leur droite par exemple on
promet des choses en retour des textes
de loi comment exactement ce qui était
dit dans leur reportage juste un instant
SMS on se rencontre il y a un certain
nombre de conseillers du gouvernement et
puis il y a les ministres du socle
terriesta qui sont quand même
spécialistes de ce genre de questions
qui sont rompus aux questions de de
négociation au Parlement et puis c'est
quoi et sur quoi et puis un tel tu
penses tu crois qu'il pense pas etc
par exemple et bien sûr et donc c'est un
peu du donnant-donnant il y a la fin bah
ça remonte à Matignon qui est censé
faire les arbitrage Jean-Claude Mailly
vous avez vécu comme syndicalistes des
périodes comme ça vous avez des
souvenirs depuis le début le
gouvernement négocier avec les
républicains et consulte les syndicats
voilà c'est c'est
fondamentalement on ne gagne rien un
pouvoir quel qu'il soit ne gagne rien à
squeezer les confédérations syndicales
quelles qu'elles soient les
confédérations patronales il y a eu
certains appels les Corinthiens de
consultation même Elisabeth on a repris
le flambeau
excusez-moi mais je simplifie
c'est pas grave CMP paritaire j'insiste
là dessus c'est pas la majorité c'est la
majorité des sénateurs et la majorité
des députés donc ça veut dire la
majorité des députés LR des sénateurs LR
et centrices et la majorité des députés
Renaissance c'est ça
donc là ils ont la majorité mais ils ont
la maladie qui trouve un compromis
ensuite ça va aller ça on imagine que
c'est possible
la droite au Sénat est plutôt alliée sur
son club
discussion ça va retourner le projet va
retourner devant l'Assemblée nationale
le gouvernement va accepter un certain
nombre d'amendements si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire qui ont été négociés
par etc et puis voilà
d'autres amendements mais pas du
gouvernement de députés qui vont
accepter pour corriger telle ou tel
point de détail etc et on va trouver un
accord ça va passer à l'Assemblée ça va
être voté ou pas bon si c'est pas voté
c'est 49-3 ou l'ordonnance les
ordonnances là vraiment ça serait un
difficulté
une lecture le Conseil constitutionnel
le Conseil consulat et c'est pour ça que
je pense moi c'est mon pari c'est qu'il
y aura deux lois il y aura cette loi si
elle passe il y aura une deuxième loi
derrière parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel sans être grand de vin
va censurer un certain nombre de
cavaliers sociaux de disposition va
faire appel ce qui nous fait rarement il
a fait deux fois ou trois fois au
principe de sincérité et de clarté c'est
un peu une auberge espagnole la clarté
la sincérité du débat parce que bon vous
voyez ce que vous voulez mais s'il a
envie de charger la barre qui pourra le
faire donc vous aurez tout de suite
après ou pas tout de suite mais peu de
temps après un deuxième mois et un
deuxième travail
et donc là avec des accords des accords
et là je sais pas s'il y a un accord
entre les républicains et LRM le 49-3
c'est quoi c'est le cauchemar pour le
gouvernement ou au contraire on assume
déjà cette arme comme possible alors on
a senti au début que c'était exclu et
puis en fait ça devient de plus en plus
ça revient sur la table là quand on
demande c'est risque faible mes risques
quand même et la question c'est
qu'est-ce qui est pire est-ce que c'est
un 49-3 ou est-ce que c'est de risquer
que le texte soit pas que les
conclusions de la commission
mixparitaire ne soient pas adoptées donc
ensuite il pourrait y avoir une nouvelle
lecture mais ce serait quand même très
compliqué pour le gouvernement donc
l'arbitrage il est sur des mauvaises
solutions mais le 49-3 alors qu'on en
parlait moins au tout début de la
réforme des retraites on en reparle
beaucoup aujourd'hui j'aurais aimé
voudrais la question de et c'est un peu
ce que disait Pradier et sans vouloir
mettre de l'eau à son moulin est-ce que
c'est le bon texte et ça c'est une
petite musique qu'on commence à entendre
qu'on entend effectivement à droite il
dit je n'ai pas voter n'importe quel
texte ça c'est Pradier mais à droite
mais au sein de la majorité on commence
aussi à l'entendre alors d'accord c'est
plutôt chez les proches d'Édouard
Philippe et qui commence à dire
nous aussi on veut réformer les traite
nous aussi on pense que c'est important
mais est-ce que finalement on sait pas
planté avec ce texte pour tout vous dire
j'en ai parlé au ministre de du travail
l'autre jour qui s'est un peu braqué et
qui m'a dit c'est le bon texte c'est moi
qui l'ai écrit bon ben voilà comme ça
c'est fait au moins il considère que que
c'est le bon texte mais quoi qu'il en
soit il y a quand même ce truc là qui
commence à monter aussi dire on est en
train quand même de cramer un capital
politique très grand il reste quatre ans
pour Emmanuel Macron au pouvoir
qu'est-ce qui va se passer socialement
et politiquement après tout ça pour une
réforme des retraites je ne dis pas
qu'elle n'est pas importante c'est pas
le sens de mon point mais politiquement
il y a quelque chose quand même de très
lourd à porter par la suite Jean-Claude
en plus que l'un des arguments présentés
par le gouvernement c'est il faut
absolument la faire il y a un problème
de déficit je n'ai pas un qui est des
problèmes financiers qu'il faille faire
quelque chose et 17 milliards
d'économies mais là avec ce qui est déjà
engagé il y a 6 milliards grosso modo de
mesures nouvelles donc qui viennent en
déduction des 17 et vous rajoutez 4
milliards à peu près de dépenses
nouvelles assurance chômage gérer ça etc
donc le 17 on est passé à 7 donc ça fait
cher et 64 ans ça fait un beau gâchis
bon on comprend on comprend que là on
est dans des scénaristes voilà c'est où
ça passe de justesse ou 49-3
géraldenas vous pensez que les Français
pourront passer à autre chose après tout
il y a deux légitimités celle du
Parlement démocratique elle doit
prévaloir sur celle de la rue est-ce que
ça les Français vont l'entendre a priori
non mais tout à fait mais il y a une
confusion permanente et tout à fait
légitime d'ailleurs en démocratie de ces
deux de ces deux scènes sociales ce que
je crois qu'ils vont résulter sans
prendre beaucoup de risques c'est par
contre une affectation négative de la
perception des Français de la vie
parlementaire c'est-à-dire que ça soit
par les mesures carnavalesques qu'on a
vu pour pour une certaine opposition ou
même les recours on va dire procédural
qu'on a vu encore d'ailleurs au même au
Sénat ça donne l'impression ça met en
scène ce que l'on sait un peu mais ce
que l'on n'a pas envie de savoir
véritablement c'est que la démocratie
délibérative dans le Parlement elle est
un peu artefactuelle et cela dévoile le
caractère artificiel de cette
délibération je pense pas que ce soit
moins que les Français ont demandé de
nouvelles règles du jeu on ne donnant
pas la majorité absolue au Président
c'est peut-être les faits inverse qui se
produit j'en Rémi Baudot il y a encore
du grain à moudre où on sait à peu près
comment on va arriver le texte on sait
que les mesures sur les femmes ont été
adoptées au Sénat qu'a priori le
gouvernement et la majorité ils sont
favorables est-ce que il pourrait y
avoir sans parler du retrait encore des
modifications substantielles c'est une
bonne question honnêtement je sais pas
forcément répondre à ça je sais pas si
Elsa a plus d'idées sur sur vraiment les
les différents points les différents
curseurs qui peuvent encore être bougés
moi
ça a été ça a été refusé moi ce qui si
on prend un peu de hauteur par rapport à
tout ça moi ce qui m'étonne quand même
c'est cette capacité de la macronie et
d'Emmanuel Macron et de l'Elysée de dire
Emmanuel Macron a été élu sur ce projet
là et donc fermer le banc il me semble
quand même malgré tout que on parlait de
l'écoute des Français tout à l'heure il
y a quand même une question qui se pose
sur voilà il a été élu mais dans un
contexte très particulier avec après une
absence de campagne etc etc et là aussi
il y a une question d'écoute écoute des
syndicats mais en réalité écoute des
français quand on sait qu'il y a 5 ans
c'était pas cette réforme des retraites
qui était dans son programme c'est pour
ça qu'il y a une réelle au sein de la
majorité sur l'après il y avait le texte
immigration qui devait arriver les
députés de la majorité on dit surtout
pas un texte aussi crispant essayons
d'aller dans des mesures qui sont pas
exactement de toute façon ils n'ont pas
la majorité mais sur des textes qui
fasse un peu plus consensus donc on
annonce un texte sur le travail pour
avoir la réflexion sur le travail que
beaucoup demandaient d'avoir avant la
réflexion sur les retraites mais
effectivement on sent bien qu'il va
falloir penser les plaies de ce moment
avec un texte qui voilà peut-être fait
du bien fait un peu plus de consensus
donc on pousse en tout cas pour voilà
des mesures qui soient un petit peu plus
acceptées par les Français l'enjeu aussi
autour de cette réforme c'est l'après
Macron il y a beaucoup de députés qui
qui vous disent attention
c'est Marine Le Pen qui qui récupère et
qui profite de cette crise je pense
qu'ils ont raison de s'inquiéter si vous
voulez moi je considère que le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui
bénéficie d'une double poussée à la fois
des
erreurs selon moi faites par la majorité
compris sur les retraites et de l'autre
côté le comportement de LFI ça fait une
double poussée pour Marine Le Pen la
prochaine fois Dominique sagnolo
mais en tout cas dans quatre ans on
verra on me l'a déjà dit ça mais le vrai
la vraie difficulté c'est que quatre ans
c'est long c'est à dire que ce que ça se
passe plutôt bien ou plutôt mal dans
tous les cas c'est ça va laisser un vide
des conséquences constitue moi j'attends
vraiment les cas patience la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel qui pourrait
d'ailleurs réconcilier tout le monde si
je puis dire
un certain nombre de dispositifs de la
loi donc
pas les 64 ans mais même alors des
régimes spéciaux pareil
l'index seniors les mesures de
pénibilité pareil je peux vous faire on
pourrait faire une liste qui est
relativement extensible il reste quand
même toujours là mais voilà donc pour
vous les les Français même adopter on
verra comment ne passeront pas autre
chose ça il y aura quelque chose qui qui
restera juste d'un mot il y a un petit
scénario qui monte aussi en macronie sur
bon une fois qu'on aura fait passer la
réforme des retraites comme de toute
façon ce sera vraiment dur on pourra
peut-être aller sur d'autres trucs aussi
très dur qui t'a être un peu sur la
lancée réformer le RSA etc et donc je
sais pas si c'est une opération kamikaze
mais il y en a quand même un certain
nombre qui se disent bah on sera sur
notre lancée allons-y quoi en tout cas
merci disait
qui commence soit le quinquennat qui
finit je pense qu'il parlait en cas
d'échec ou pas d'échec de la réforme des
retraites mais on peut même parler en
cas d'atmosphère générale pour Emmanuel
Macron effectivement soit ça commence
soit c'est compliqué pour l'instant
merci pour ce décryptage on a une
semaine on va conserver ça forcément sur
LCP de très très près 49-3 ou pas
adoption ou pas et que va rester ce que
va devenir ce mouvement social elles
sont là les questions merci merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat dans une
dizaine de minutes j'irai bonheur on va
parler de votre livre dans un instant
mais non pas nos affranchis sont déjà
prêts vous les voyez d'abord Yanis roder
au centre bien entouré qui va revenir
sur l'autocensure grandissante des chefs
d'établissement sur les attentes à la
laïcité nouvelle histoire d'école à
venir et puis que Ridel de l'Institut
Rousseau revient sur les reculs
terribles des droits des femmes dans le
monde pointer par l'ONU enfin Isabelle
Lasserre va nous parler de la situation
Géorgie entre lois liberticide
manifestation pro-européenne et
influence russe mais d'abord comme prévu
on se plonge dans votre livre Gérald
Brunner je le disais et c'est personnel
et réflexions théoriques sur la question
des origines au pluriel pourquoi
devient-on qui l'on est on en parle
juste après l'invitation signée ce soir
par Marco poli
si on vous invite Gérald Debrunner c'est
parce que vous posez une question
existentielle pourquoi devient-on qui
l'on est dans votre dernier livre vous
interrogez vos origines pour mieux
comprendre votre identité faisant de
vous l'objet d'études de votre propre
réflexion sociologique longtemps je n'ai
pas su de quel milieu je venais à un
moment j'ai compris ma famille et moi
nous étions pauvres pauvre mais pas
malheureux vous le fils d'une femme de
ménage qui avait grandi dans une cité
HLM de Nancy adolescent la culture
c'était la télévision dites-vous au
cinéma comment littérature vaut
références sont populaires Excalibur le
Seigneur des Anneaux de Tolkien de quoi
expliquer peut-être votre penchant pour
le mystique c'est pas quelque chose qui
est totalement déraisonnable que de
chemin parcourus Gérald Debrunner
aujourd'hui sociologue professeur à la
Sorbonne membre de l'Académie nationale
de médecine les postes s'enchaînent les
livres à succès aussi une trajectoire
qui vous mènera jusqu'à l'Elysée enfin
presque spécialiste des phénomènes
d'opinion vous présidez en 2021 une
commission sur la désinformation et le
complotisme ascension sociale fulgurante
donc ce qui fait de vous un translate je
me définis plutôt comme un nomade social
tout simplement parce que j'ai pas
l'impression ni d'avoir trahi mon milieu
d'origine point de trahison ni de honte
pas de dolorisme non plus car ça vous
irrite dans votre bouche aucun étalage
de douleur de tristesse sur votre passé
quant au futur il ne peut se résumer à
nos origines sociales dites-vous la
biologie notre socialisation compte
aussi sans oublier une part de mystère
c'est votre thèse alors Gérald Debrunner
une question nous taraude ce soir
avez-vous enfin compris pourquoi vous
êtes devenu ce que vous êtes
[Musique]
réponse
c'est évidemment toujours une quête
qu'on cherche tous à mener et
qui nous conduit toujours à une forme
d'échec la vraie question c'est comment
échouer pas trop mal c'est à dire je
vais jamais réussir vraiment à me
rencontrer moi-même parce que tout ce
que je vais dire de moi-même relève
d'une fiction je vais reconstruire un
certain nombre d'éléments et puis je
vais choisir des éléments dans mon passé
pour me raconter une histoire seulement
il y a des histoires plus fautives que
d'autres ce que j'essaie modestement de
faire dans ce livre c'est bah de
discuter avec le lecteur de savoir
quelles sont les grands pièges narratifs
ou éviter on va venir mais cette
question des origines elle n'avait pas
de soi pour vous au début elle s'est pas
posée vous voulez pas poser comment elle
est venue et comment vous avez décidé
finalement d'écrire ce livre
sans que Alexandre Lacroix qui est
responsable de cette collection puis qui
dirige aussi Philosophie Magazine vous
savez me les meuler tout simplement
proposé d'abord au début j'avais dit non
parce qu'on n'avait pas fixé un thème et
la spécificité de la collection c'est
d'abord des thèmes en se dévoilant un
peu soi-même un peu d'analytique un peu
d'autobiographie je t'ai pas tellement
chaud et vous dites pour le faire que
c'est la question de la destination qui
vous habitait davantage qu'est-ce que je
vais devenir où je vais aller plus que
la question de où je viens tout au fond
vous dites même que vous êtes un milieu
très modeste vous êtes fils de femme de
ménage vous avez grandi dans un HLM près
de Nancy mais que vous étiez dans un
environnement joyeux plutôt heureux et
qu'au fond vous avez découvert par les
autres que vous étiez pauvre ben oui
mais comme beaucoup d'ailleurs parce que
en fait on ne se comprend soi-même quand
on se compare en aux autres donc quand
vous fréquentez des enfants de milieux
très modestes comme vous vous imaginez
pas d'abord que vous êtes pauvre c'est
cette cette constatation elle vient
progressivement quand vous par exemple
quand vous accédez au lycée ce qui était
pas encore si fréquent à mon à mon
époque que vous allez vers le
baccalauréat et à vous rencontrez des
enfants
qui sont dans les parents sont médecins
ingénieurs ils partent en vacances au
sport divers par exemple ils reviennent
bronzer ça je me souviens joue ils
avaient des marques blanches je
comprenais pas exactement à quoi ça
correspondait puis les vêtements de
marque ça compte beaucoup quand on est
adolescent en terme de distinction tout
seul donc je l'ai appris progressivement
et à fortiorer quand je suis devenu
professeur d'université quand même pas
mal d’universitaires qui viennent de
milieux plutôt plutôt aisés j'ai
découvert d'autres mondes sociaux mais
sans en effet chercher à faire avouer au
passé les un certain nombre de choses
quoi alors la question des translate est
très présente aujourd'hui vous dites nos
bêtes sociales n'est pas trop cette
expression elle est présente dans les
récits littéraires elle est présente au
cinéma celle qui au fond la représente
le mieux cette question c'est Annie
Ernaux prix Nobel de littérature il y a
d'autres écrivains on pense à Didier
ribbon aussi Edward Louis le récit
traduit au fond ce que vous appelez
l'obsession narrative doloriste
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est ce qui m'a
frappé quand je me suis mis à écrire ce
livre donc je me suis plongé dans cette
littérature et ça a été tout à fait
frappant ce Doloris c'est-à-dire une
forme d'exaltation de la douleur c'est
qu'on ne se raconte soi-même qu'en
mettant en avant un certain nombre
d'éléments dont je conteste pas la
réalité ni même les affects c'est pas
qui m'intéresse mais en tant que
sociologue et en particulier social des
croyances et donc des fictions des
narrations je me suis demandé mais
comment se fait-il que cette littérature
finalement qui décrit des ascensions
sociales elle est elle existe depuis le
19e siècle et on a des figures au 20e
siècle son journal Albert Camus tout
simplement il y en a beaucoup d'autres
et comment se fait-il donc que cette
littérature là n'est pas mise en avant
ses affects et que tout à coup il y a
une forme de mode qui surgit et qui qui
évoque sans cesse
le terme revient censé d'ailleurs même
un roman Dani Arnaud qui s'appelle la
honte et quand Chantal Jacquet qui est
d'ailleurs est celle qui a inventé le
terme transclass réuni un certain nombre
de personnes dans un livre collectif
Paris ou presque universel de France que
je me suis empressé de lire et bien le
pour parler des trans classes ce sont
des trans classes qui parlent
d'eux-mêmes souvent des universitaires
des chercheurs le terme de honte revient
sans cesse ont été culpabilité
absolument or moi je ne ressentais pas
du tout cela personnellement plutôt de
la fierté ce qui paraît ce qui peut très
très banal mais j'essaie d'être sincère
c'est pour ça que j'ai failli d'ailleurs
renoncer à écrire ce livre parce que
tout au long de l'écriture je me
demandais est-ce que j'arriverai à être
sincère jusqu'au bout alors c'est pas à
moi de le dire mais en tout cas je suis
allé jusqu'au bout de ce livre et je me
suis dit que cette mode narrative c'est
obsession en fait narrative elle avait
un sens en réalité elle ne vient pas de
n'importe où ce sont tout tous les gens
que vous avez évoqué Eribon Edward Louis
et en particulier à nierno sont des
lecteurs de Pierre Bourdieu dans les
électeurs des admirateurs moi aussi
j'admire une partie en tout cas de son
œuvre c'est un très grand sociologue et
effectivement elle parle de révélation
ontologique de chocontologique à dire
non en lisant un Bourdieu et du coup
effectivement quand vous changez de
classe sociale c'est un peu par votre
expérience une négation au moins une
altération de la grande thèse de
Bourdieu de la reproduction sociale qui
reste vraie statistiquement bien entendu
vous avez moins de chance de réussir
dans la dans la vie professionnellement
si vous venez d'un milieu modeste que si
vous venez d'un milieu favoriser et on a
l'impression qu'il cherche à s'excuser
d'apporter une contradiction à cette
thèse alors donc oui ils ont traversé
les mondes sociaux mais ils s'en excuse
en quelque sorte et il s'en excuse en
exhibant une forme de douleur mais
qu'est-ce que ce récit alors doloriste
que vous décrivez cette obsession de
l'époque vous dites même que c'est le
discours le récit dominant aujourd'hui
assez récit dominant par sa visibilité
mais il est certainement par mon avis
représentatif de la part des
translations oui les dominant bah par la
notoriété de ceux qui le servent jusqu'à
un prix Nobel et là je juge pas du tout
de la qualité littéraire je suis pas du
tout apte à faire cela mais en effet on
a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui j'espère
jusqu'à mon livre en tout cas les trans
classes pour prendre la parole dans
l'espace public se sentait obligé
d'exhiber cette honte sinon il n'était
pas tout à fait légitime depuis que j'ai
publié ce livre j'ai reçu véritablement
des centaines de témoignages que je ne
supporte de parole de personnes je
t'apporte-parole des translate
certainement pas mais en tout cas de
gens qui se prétendaient transclasses
qui me racontent leur vie c'est assez
émouvant des parcours
tout à fait extraordinaire bien plus que
le mien et et qui disent merci qui me
disent merci tout simplement parce que
votre parole m'a soulagé en fait ça ça
pesait sur leur sur leurs épaules en
fait comme un couvercle lourd ce récit
de Loris il y a vous baladez donc un
petit peu vous donner un petit coup de
pied à cette façon de ce récit narratif
là Freud aussi vous considérez qu'on a
quelque chose un peu
d'obsédé d'obsessionnel avec l'idée
qu'on ramènerait tout à notre histoire
familiale
aux injonctions parentales ça met en
scène que ce soit la psychanalyse encore
une fois c'est pas une attaque réglée
contre la psychanalyse mais en termes
narratif ça met en scène la grande
erreur qu'il ne faut pas commettre et
parlons-en quelle est cette grande
erreur narrative qui vaut pas commettre
quand on cherche à se rencontrer
soi-même c'est d'indexer l'intégralité
de sa personnalité sur une seule
variable à ne faire tenir la complexité
de ce que nous sommes de ce que nous
sommes devenus
c'est normal de le faire on va chercher
par exemple dans la psychanalyse
quelques traumas qui expliquerait
l'intégralité de notre vie mais
seulement dans la vraie vie ça arrive ça
dans les fictions toutes les fictions
maintenant sont basées là-dessus quand
vous avez le héros d'une série télé ou
d'un film s'il a une personnalité un
petit peu fragile ou bancale etc qui
cherchent on cherche à lire ça vient
toujours d'un trauma c'est le côté
rosebud vous savez on voit déjà ça vient
du père alors que vous vous dites
attention on doit beaucoup aussi à nos
pères pairs ce que nous sommes c'est
évidemment multifactoriel bien sûr que
nos parents leur catégorie sociale etc
ça a une influence sur ce que nous
allons devenir en termes de statistiques
et de probabilité mais les études le
montrent et bien les amis les premiers
cercles que nous rencontrons alors au
bas de nos immeubles pour moi ou même
tout simplement dans les collèges dans
les lycées notre groupe de père pas IRS
comme vous l'avez dit à une énorme
influence on le sait par exemple parce
que tout simplement les accents on peut
conserver l'accent de ses parents c'est
le cas chez les hispanophones aux on
conserve l'accent expanophone mais pas
chez les russophone pourtant eux aussi
ont des parents qui ont un accent mais
simplement parce que les russophone
fréquentent moins de ruissophobe que les
ispanophones de fréquentent
d'hispanophone donc voilà comment aussi
on reproduit un certain nombre
d'éléments je voudrais qu'on parle du
Mérite parce que cette question au fond
on est ce qu'on
est des efforts du travail de ce qu'on a
de ce qu'on a accompli vous le battez en
brèche vous dites que la méritocratie
n'a pas tenu ses promesses que c'est une
fiction on le voit bien à la France
produit des inégalités et c'est un
record en Europe mais en même temps vous
dites cette fiction il faut la conserver
parce qu'elle est utile pourquoi c'est
une fiction utile comme comme toute
chose il faut voir les alternatives les
alternatives à cette fiction sont
d'autres fictions par exemple le
fatalisme social c'est-à-dire tu n'as
aucune chance de réussir etc qui
imprègne aussi un certain nombre de
notamment de jeunes de quartiers
modestes on le voit par exemple dans le
rap j'en donne quelques quelques par
exemple et là ça c'est assez terrible
parce que ça peut devenir des prophéties
autorisatrices je donne un exemple qui
issu de des travaux d'anthropologue en
l'occurrence d'un anthropologue sur les
a chantilles du Gana c'est une
population qui croit que
les gens sont déterminés par leur jour
de naissance ils leur donnent un prénom
particulier et ils disent que ceux qui
sont nés le lundi seront plus vertus que
ceux qui sont le vendredi or dans les
statistiques des tribunaux cette
croyance elle est confirmée c'est-à-dire
qu'on trouve beaucoup plus de gens qui
ont ce prénom et qui sont nés le
vendredi sauf si vous croyez la
puissance des prénoms ce qui est pas mon
cas et bien vous ne pouvez pas imaginer
autre chose que le fait d'un certain
fatalisme social il va devenir une forme
de prophétie autoralisatrice alors je
pense qu'il faut tout simplement pas
prendre les gens pour des idiots
c'est-à-dire que la statistique est
comme une mère cruelle mais qu'il faut
écouter en effet il y a une reproduction
des inégalités dans notre pays comme
dans beaucoup d'autres pays mais
cependant les alternatives narratives
sont bien pires et quand je parle de
fiction pour la méritocratie c'est pas
moi qui le dis c'est François Dubé un
meilleur spécialiste de ces questions
nécessaires et je lui reprends ce en
tout cas c'est passionnant cette
question des origines il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire aussi sur l'école
malheureusement on n'a pas le temps je
vais renvoyer les lecteurs vous parlez
de diplôme manie l'obsession justement
de la reconnaissance par le diplôme et
il y a tout a changé là-dessus pourquoi
devient-on qui l'on est c'est donc aux
éditions les grands mots autrement et
c'est signé Gérald Brenner vous restez
avec moi on va accueillir nos
affranchies à présent leur parti pris
tout de suite c'est à vous
alors trois affranchis ce soir il y a
des frauder une nouvelle histoire
d'école on y vient dans un instant et
puis mademoiselle Chloé Ridel qu'on est
ravis de retrouver de l'Institut
Rousseau qui nous parle du droit des
femmes et la situation Géorgie ce soir
avec Isabelle Lasserre Yanis on commence
par vous vous revenez sur une étude
sortie hier sur la laïcité qui vous a
particulièrement interpellé oui Myriam
l'information la plus saisissante du
sondage du SNPDEN le principal syndicat
des chefs d'établissement nous montre
que les chefs d'établissements sont 42%
à avoir constaté le port de tenue
religieuse au sein de leur établissement
mais qu'ils sont 43% donc près d'un sur
deux à ne pas les signaler ces atteintes
à la laïcité passe donc sous les radars
du ministère selon l'étude les chefs
d'établissements manquent de temps mais
se méfient aussi des réactions de leur
hiérarchie le fameux pas de vague si
vous voulez régulièrement dénoncer ils
sont également 37% à ne pas signaler les
contestations de cours au nom de vérités
religieuses et 71% les chiffres
impressionnants à ne pas signaler des
évitements par les élèves de cours de PS
et notamment de natation pour des
raisons également religieuses cela
signifie en réalité que les chiffres du
ministère qui rappelons-le et le
ministre le dit lui-même ne sont pas des
statistiques car ils sont basés sur des
déclarations ne nous donne que des
tendances et non pas un état des lieux
alors quel est-il cet état des lieux
selon vous réellement il est plutôt
inquiétant Myriam kersé question si elle
reste concentrée dans les métropoles et
leurs banlieue et davantage bien sûr
dans les établissements en réseau
d'éducation prioritaire et les fameux
repas qu'ailleurs prennent de l'ampleur
et s'étendent de plus ce sondage issu de
l'intérieur même de l'état de
l'éducation nationale puisque sur
l'échelle des établissements vient
corroborer d'autres études qui depuis
2018 vont tout dans le même sens et
montrent une aggravation de la situation
sur le terrain la dernière enquête Ifop
sortie lundi 6 mars donc il y a quelques
jours nous apprend par exemple que 44%
des enseignants ont déjà observé un
problème lié à une question religieuse
depuis septembre 2021 et 30% des
enseignants de crêpes disent avoir été
victime l'agression physique liée à des
tensions de nature religieuse
l'identitaire au coût de leur carrière
un taux ahurissant et que fait le
gouvernement le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale a pris l'ampleur du phénomène
il me semble le ministre a pris une
circulaire le 9 novembre dernier pour
venir au soutien des chefs
d'établissement mais aussi pour insister
sur la nécessité de former et former en
priorité les personnels de l'érection à
ces questions de laïcité bon alors vous
vous en pensez quoi Yanis moi je pense
Myriam que cette mesure cette circulaire
de l'ensemble elle est très importante
mais que le problème est profond et que
si formez tous les personnels est
essentiels évidemment il faut aussi
redonner à l'école et aux métiers
d'enseignant toutes leurs dimensions il
faut dire que l'école n'est pas
seulement le lieu de l'instruction mais
qu'elle est aussi le lieu de la
construction républicaine il faut donc
repoliser au sens noble et non partisans
du terme évidemment la mission
enseignante pour voir à nouveau répondre
à ce que nous disait le grand pédagogue
et homme politique Ferdinand Buisson le
rôle de la République c'est de faire des
républicains merci il reste optimiste et
Yanis roder vous êtes
[Musique]
trouver une femme qui a publié hier un
rapport qui est assez alarmant puisqu'il
estime que l'objectif d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes dont le monde
s'éloignent de plus en plus et Antonio
guterrese qui est secrétaire général des
Nations unies par le même de régression
il dit que le progrès effectué depuis
des décennies disparaissent sous nos
yeux et il donne ce chiffre un peu
étrange il dit au rythme actuel
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
ne sera pas atteintes avant 300 ans
alors pour l'ONU la constitue une menace
pour le développement humain évidemment
pour l'écologie et pour la sécurité oui
parce que l'égalité des gens ce n'est
pas seulement un droit fondamental ça
n'est pas seulement un impératif de
justice c'est aussi un principe
nécessaire pour l'instauration d'un
monde prospère pacifique et durable ce
sont les termes de l'ONU Prosper parce
qu'il est largement démontré que
l'égalité d'accès aux fonctions
économiques professionnelles entre les
femmes et les hommes favorise le
développement d'une société améliore le
taux d'emploi et aussi la productivité
mais aussi le machisme l'absence
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
en plus d'être révoltante c'est quelque
chose qui coûte énormément à la société
au finances publiques le système de
santé de police de justice et rien qu'en
France l'ONU estime que les inégalités
entre les femmes et les hommes coûtent
118 milliards d'euros chaque année
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est aussi le gage d'un monde plus
écologique qui a eu cette étude publiée
cette semaine par la Banque de France
qui montre notamment que les femmes sont
moins consommatrices de viande de
carburants qui sont deux sources de
pollution majeures et qu'elles sont plus
sensibles aux pratiques écolos ça se
remarque dans la sphère privée que ce
soit au niveau du régime alimentaire des
loisirs ou encore du mode de transport
les femmes génèrent généralement moins
de gaz à effet de serre que les hommes
mais c'est aussi en vrai en entreprise
puisque quand les femmes accèdent aux
responsabilités elles vont plus souvent
mener l'entreprise vers des pratiques
environnementales plus vertueuses et
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
garantit aussi la paix dans le monde je
voudrais insister sur ce point parce que
je crois qu'on en parle encore trop peu
pourtant alors que l'Europe et le
théâtre d'une guerre ils devraient nous
intéresser ce point-là parce qu'on voit
bien qu'il existe un continuum entre la
violence patriarcale et la violence des
relations internationales entre le
virilisme et la guerre comme moyen de
parvenir à ses fins il y a bien
évidemment sous nos yeux l'exemple de
Vladimir Poutine qui a mobilise une
rhétorique masculiniste vis-à-vis de
l'Ukraine il avait parlé de l'Ukraine en
ces termes en disant que tu le veuilles
ou non ma jolie tu devras t'y faire donc
c'est une sorte de logique l'Ukraine se
détourne de moi choisi l'Europe donc je
la tue à ce propos hier une diplomate
française qui est ambassadrice de France
auprès de l'OTAN parler d'une culture
géopolitique du viol et je crois qu'elle
a parfaitement raison puisque la culture
du viol dont on parle beaucoup existe
aussi dans les relations entre pays
alors en mettant fin au virilisme au
patriarcat en arrivant à l'égalité des
droits entre les genres à l'échelle
mondiale en faisant en sorte que les
femmes accèdent aux responsabilités
politiques partout dans le monde ont
contribuera oui à pacifier les relations
internationales et nous en avons
tellement besoin pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique là aussi les
chiffres de l'Organisation onufam sont
assez éclairants puisqu'il est prouvé
que la participation des femmes
négociation de paix aboutit à des paix
plus stables plus durable on a aussi
remarqué en étudiant les données de 153
pays de 90 à 2019 qu'il existait un lien
fort entre la militarisation d'une
société et les inégalités de genre donc
pour résumer climat paix féminisme tout
cela est lié et l'égalité de droit entre
les femmes et les hommes partout dans le
monde ça n'est pas seulement un
impératif de justice une vertu
économique ou encore logique c'est aussi
une de nos meilleures garanties de
sécurité un commentaire une réaction
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour mettre des
femmes partout oui enfin il faudrait
regarder tous ces chiffres en détail
pour être tout à fait tout à fait
honnête parce que corrélation n'est pas
causalité mais oui c'est ça en tout cas
c'est un combat absolument essentiel
pour l'avenir notre notre espèce tout
simplement notre espèce à un moment où
dans le monde elle recule terriblement
Iran Afghanistan et j'en passe merci
Chloé
Isabelle direction la Géorgie que pays
que vous connaissez bien il y a des
grosses manifestations il y a une loi
liberticide qui a failli voilà être
adopté mais qui a été retiré qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans ce pays qui s'enflamme
à nouveau bah écoutez il se pourrait se
passer la même chose que en Ukraine vous
souvenez Myriam en 2014 à maïdan c'était
l'association avec l'Union européenne
qui avait provoqué ces énormes
manifestations et qui avait chassé le
pouvoir prorus de Kiev et ben adilici
c'est autre chose c'est une loi qui
s'appelle la loi contre les agents
étrangers qui a précipité dans la rue
des dizaines de milliers de manifestants
ils ont été assez violemment réprimés
par la police alors qu'est-ce qu'elle
dit cette loi elle dit que toutes les
organisations toutes les ONG financées à
au moins 20% par des fonds étrangers
doivent s'inscrire comme étant des une
organisation des agents de l'étranger
alors concrètement ça veut dire qu'on
peut les fermer les faire taire et puis
concrètement aussi ça permet d'empêcher
de manière préventive le rapprochement
de la Géorgie à l'Union européenne donc
ils sont descendus dans la rue on a vu
des drapeaux européens les Géorgiens le
pouvoir à retirer cette loi la crise
elle n'est pas terminée elle n'est pas
terminée parce que les revendications
des manifestants sont en fait beaucoup
plus larges c'est à dire qu'il
protestent contre la politique prorus
menée par le pouvoir georgien depuis
plusieurs années depuis que le le parti
le rêve georgien a gagné les élections
en 2012 elle est orchestrée dans l'ombre
cette politique prorus par un oligarque
qui s'appelle bidzina evanisvili qui est
un oligarque proche du Kremlin et qui
possède à peu près 40% du PIB de la
Géorgie il tient dans sa main tous les
responsables politiques y compris la
présidence Salomé zohrabichili qui a
d'ailleurs un passeport français puisque
c'est une ancienne diplomate française
et qui est devenue sa marionnette alors
depuis qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir le
rêve georgien a en cause la plupart des
réformes pro-européennes et
pro-démocratiques il y avait été mise en
place par l'ancien président Missa
Michaël Vili qui avait été élu à la
suite déjà d'une première révolution la
Révolution
des Roses en 2003 et depuis la de on
voit que aussi que depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine en fait la Georgie ne
soutient absolument pas l'Ukraine elle
n'a pas appliqué les les sanctions
décidées par l'Occident contre la Russie
elle jette ses opposants et les
dissidents en prison d'ailleurs l'ancien
président Missa shakajili il croupit
depuis octobre 2021 et aujourd'hui ça
sentait tellement mauvaise qu'on craint
d'ailleurs pour sa vie alors ça veut
dire quoi pour la suite la Géorgie
pourrait connaître le même sort que
l'Ukraine alors peut-être oui
c'est-à-dire que comme l'Ukraine la
Géorgie est occupée 20% de son
territoire à peu près est occupé par les
forces russes et comme en Ukraine en
fait la population est majoritairement
pro-européenne le dernier sondage la
donne à 85 % pro européennes alors elle
voit cette population petit à petit ses
rêves de démocratie et de rapprochement
avec l'Union européenne s'évaporer sous
la pression du pouvoir Probus parce que
en genre en juin 2022 les trois pays qui
avaient fait quand acte de candidature à
l'Union européenne c'est à dire la
Moldavie l'Ukraine et la Géorgie et bien
la l'Ukraine et la Moldavie ont eu un
oui de l'Union européenne et la Géorgie
un nom parce que l'Europe a constaté ses
recules démocratiques alors depuis et
comment comment Ukraine d'ailleurs comme
un Maidan depuis le début de la semaine
les manifestants quand ils manifestent
brandissent à la fois des drapeaux
Georgiens des drapeaux Ukrainiens ça
c'est nouveau mais aussi des drapeaux
avec les étoiles de l'Europe ils
aimeraient suivre l'exemple de l'Ukraine
alors on verra dans les prochains jours
parce que et là c'est vraiment un
problème pour la Géorgie mais
l'opposition Georgienne est vraiment
divisé alors on va voir si elle va avoir
le courage des Ukrainiens et manifester
pendant plusieurs mois ou si cette
révolte au lieu d'être une révolution ne
sera qu'un feu de paille
Brunner vous pensez que l'exemple
ukrainien voilà peut aimer dans d'autres
dans d'autres pays comme la Géorgie qui
avait avec sa cache fili on s'en
souvient déjà fait sa propre révolution
les deux sont peut-être pas en effet
décorrélés ce qu'on espère pour la
Géorgie c'est que l'exemple ukrainien la
protégera en quelque sorte parce que ce
serait une drôle d'aventure de
recommencer les choses ou de la mener en
parallèle par exemple pour la Russie
mais j'avoue que j'écoute avec intérêt
et avec grande incompétence
a dit votre expert sur le sujet Isabelle
du Figaro correspondante du film garrot
Yanis roder et ses histoires d'école
enseignant en Seine-Saint-Denis en
histoire et Chloé Ridel de l'Institut
Rousseau merci à vous merci Gérald
Brunet merci de nous avoir accompagné ce
soir les origines pourquoi devient-on
qu'il en est c'est-à-dire dans la
collection
les grands mots autrement très belle
soirée documentaire qui commence
maintenant avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à
demain
[Musique]